[Music]
[Applause]
my very first sober Super Bowl in like
15 years thank you uh Tommy for your
commitment but I did have six Coke Zero
so sobriety is a frame of mind
let's go
welcome back to the break room now this
is normally our afternoon Daily Show
that keeps you updated on all the nerdy
news you need to know but we're doing a
special one tonight because we knew we
were going to get so many awesome
trailers in the Super Bowl in the Super
Bowl for the most part didn't disappoint
including the quality of the game though
this ain't no Sports show go Chiefs go
shout out crane brewing in uh Kansas
City shout out refs the the 12th man the
true 12th man in this game we already
lost the audience I'm kidding
congratulations Chiefs fan but tonight
we are going to go through we are going
to play and react to all the big
trailers uh We Got Tonight included and
maybe some of the smaller trailers too
um already on the new Rochester's
Channel Eric Voss has a reaction video
to The Flash trailer obviously
breakdowns for The Flash trailer the
Guardians the Galaxy vol 3 trailer maybe
one or two others will be coming out
there's a couple key trailers oh we're
working on some technical difficulties
with my if my sound is whacked uh a
couple big troubles we did not get that
we might talk about as well thank you
Jessica
um but uh oh and of course with me to do
that as I just mentioned Jessica Clemons
is here
hello Tommy bechtold is here hello and
you're here in the chat we're gonna be
leaning on you a lot tonight uh already
we've run a poll we're gonna uh read
those results in a moment but throw out
your questions coming out of these
trailers your favorite moments the most
intriguing uh frames or sequences or
anything like that we're gonna try to
answer all the questions uh react to the
the big comments as we go tonight uh
just real quick and we're gonna get to
the uh Guardians trailer first uh but
big takeaways in general
um I didn't get a Marvel's trailer
that's my biggest takeaway I'm very
upset Marvel Studios I'm happy with
Guardians not happy about actually no
Disney happy Guardians not happy about
the Little Mermaid and not happy about
it and no Disney plus I have I was
thinking suspicion the remainder of this
week will be rich with Disney trailer
content dropping which is fine but let's
also not forget Disney's pretty smart
about this Guardians is going to be a
huge franchise they've got a huge movie
coming out this week yeah so we don't
necessarily need to muddy the waters
with other uh other things coming out I
will say what big things for me
uh I think someone super chatted we have
heard so much about this Flash movie
we've heard yeah it's so great everybody
uh everybody in the company talking the
company lines this movie's incredible
people who are industry scoopers and
insiders this movie is incredible based
on that trailer it's hard to disagree
with that that was a uh what the kids
call a banger of a track and as we were
talking about uh have you watched the
full online version three minutes yeah
like us there's a lot of meat on that
bone yeah three minutes is an eternity
ask my wife
you're not married uh okay but hey how
about let's jump right into it what you
came here for let's let's roll this new
uh Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 trailer
and on the flip side we'll come back
we'll react we'll answer some questions
we'll get into it Dash will play that
funky
[Music]
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
I formed the Guardians
meta girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
[Music]
came back a totaled dick oh please he
left out some important information but
that is the gist of it
[Music]
my sacred mission
is to create the perfect Society
I want to make things perfect
he just hated things the way they are
God
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
to fight this side my friends
incinerate them
we're always searching for a family
until we found each other
are you ready
for One Last Ride
I'll fly away together
into the forever
a beautiful sky
[Applause]
whoever it was that you were in love
with it sounds more like her hers do not
bring me into them
knock it off what
just never noticed how black your eyes
were they were replaced by my father as
a method of torture he he picked a
pretty set
the ancestors also that and I thought
you were talking about because I was
like mantis's eyes are completely black
what is he talking about uh and that is
his sister you can't date your own
sister and you shouldn't date two people
that are related I think a really big
takeaway from this is remembering
because this trailer we were talking
about before it actually started was how
happy it kind of is and how rom-coming
it is but match that to the trailers
that we got in the past where we have uh
Peter Quill crying screaming in a white
room and we assume he's working on
rocket and when we see that white room
what we've seen in the eyes of Rocket is
the high evolutionary working on him and
writing numbers or it could be that
prison that they're in so he's either
blood like curdling scream crying in
that prison or with the high of where
the high evolutionary does all his male
practices at oh man yeah my favorite bar
yeah Boys Town in Chicago you've
committed malpractice on this show
um but yeah that we yeah the biggest
takeaway obviously tonally this this
Trail is framed around uh Star-Lord and
gamora's relationship right and it's
like it opens that's very Cameron Crowe
you know rom-com uh you know
Elizabethtown or uh Almost Famous or
whatever and then you know we got a lot
of the similar shots and different
action sequences in the middle but then
we also end on like a purely comedic
moment too right I love the shots that
we're getting but I feel like which
Marvel has been doing and I it maybe
it's only me that gets upset give it a
little bit too much away because we see
that scene where um where uh Groot is
landing on Adam Warlock is the same
location and scene where he's beating
the hell out of uh nagamora of nebula
right when he was beating the hell out
of nebula at the same place so we're
like what is Adam Warlock doing you guys
even mentioned before this happened he's
not talking yeah we've still yet to get
I think any Adam Warlock dialogue this
trailer was a little heavier on high
evolutionary we got he said more shots
okay I want to come back to that I want
to come back to that but still no some
different shots of uh um Adam were like
like flying and fighting obviously but
he hasn't said anything and Jessica you
were saying well he's a baby right maybe
he can't speak also we know from like
the comics that he basically the high
evolutionary takes him under his wing
like a father so if uh Alicia made him
he got lost somewhere in space found by
the high evolutionary that re whatever
he did to Rocket he did to him and is
now constructed out of more like to be
his like little slave pet and that's why
he's just destroying and rampaging
through these cities yeah
um I I I I I'm still stuck on that's
what Adam warlock's gonna be I think it
was somewhere else something somewhere
saying that he was like just brand new
because we know he's just getting out of
that cocoon he's a little caterpillar
butterfly just a dumb idiot one did you
know the caterpillars completely
dissolve and then reform molecularly
into butter no they don't yeah they turn
into goo are you watching don't we all
um I do whenever I watch a Marvel
trailer uh hey yo we want to talk about
the high evolutionary he does he changes
haircuts depending on the shots we've
seen shots where he's completely bald
but then when he says like incinerate
he's got some LeVar Burton yeah he's got
some hair over here and so you were
speculating right like we're probably
gonna see flashbacks to maybe when he
was creating or working on rocket and
then kind of present day Guardians going
after him whatever
um so it's interesting that incinerate
them he's probably not talking about the
Guardians no I was talking about
something else [__] his friends
what if it's Rocket's friends he
incinerates the animals oh no I knew a
guy that used to the centering animals
oh what
um also
um uh uh Paul K in the Super Chat saying
where gamora's eyes blue at the start of
the trailer I did not notice I did not
pick up on that detail I'm not a pupil
guy but I mean people uh eye color was a
significant kind of punchline in in that
uh trailer
um uh frostenberg said why are they
carrying Peter at the end of theory yes
I think he's just knocked out yeah oh
he's dead yeah I also I'm more concerned
about Gamora why is she there clearly
she doesn't want to be there is she
captive is there something that she's
trying to distract like hold on with
them well she does at the end of end
game
save her sister right like she does a
saver so maybe maybe it's all nebula
maybe it's maybe she's lost in the in
the universe and seeking out family and
you know Guardians is all about finding
family yeah or or or there could be
right we think she's gone back to maybe
lead a crew of ravagers she's out there
doing some bounty hunting or whatever
maybe they're kind of like she was after
whatever the same prize is that the
Guardians are you know maybe that's also
related to high evolutionary we were
talking about we got a lot more shots of
a new set piece like this white and pink
uh kind of very fun looking location do
we have an image of that Dash all
we do not have it okay but picture it in
your mind's eye picture a creamsicle
yeah uh and it seems like that's also
where that that last shot where the joke
with the your black eyes is taking place
there and we were speculating based on
like the costumes and kind of some of
what that set looks like maybe that's a
different kind of prison yeah the
Guardians I mean they met in prison
maybe they're back in some kind of jail
I'm tagging out because the refrigerator
door is open thank you thank you uh
Emerson Whiteside caterpillars do not
completely dissolve many cells do
disconnect and migrate along membranes
but they are never completely liquid
Mr White coming in with the knowledge
thank you uh and you know what if this
needs to become a biology live stream
we'll go there I love it we'll see it
um
uh your mic is still on though uh yeah
all right so we ran a poll uh right when
we were first going live favorite
trailer of the night uh The Flash coming
in with 49 and we're gonna get to The
Flash trailer but Guardians volume three
right behind it at 43 then it's a pretty
steep drop-off to Crete 3 and dial of
Destiny both of which
like Air Jordan oh uh um
Matt Damon joint yes Tommy keeps wanting
to talk about it on the show that looks
like a lifetime movie starring movie
stars yeah and that they that trailer
actually they played it during the Super
Bowl I did release earlier did you say
lifetime doesn't cast movies dies well
like famous movie stars not like movie
stars from the 80s not Judith Light or
yeah Meredith Baxter Bernie or something
I have no disrespect no dispers
wonderful actors hey get work uh also we
had another uh somebody in the chat
saying what do you think that stone is
in Adam warlock's head because it can't
be the Soul Stone right we talked about
we theorize it on the break room before
we had an entire episode dedicated onto
it with mt uh I recommend going back to
it because I forgot what I said I
thought maybe it was some kind of
battery
test test
yeah and maybe if there is a connection
there through the high evolutionary like
he's a fan of putting weird stud looking
things in the backs of animals maybe
this is like a similar kind of element
sure yeah hopefully we'll find out um
okay uh uh I think there's a lot to talk
about with guardians volume three we're
probably gonna talk about it throughout
the week on the break room uh Eric Voss
will be doing a trailer breakdown coming
out on the channel probably tomorrow
um but we have a lot of other trailers
we want to get so many more trailers uh
including uh fast 10 there's some new
footage Transformers rise of the beasts
uh uh Isle of Destiny dial of Destiny
and of course flash there's so much to
talk about with the flash uh but first
let's roll into a little Creed Three why
not Kang and um killmonger yes
ready or not
um
[Music]
[Applause]
there may have been a time when Damien
had your back
but he doesn't anymore
hey I'm just getting started little
brother
I'm coming for everything
[Applause]
don't let him destroy everything you've
built
and they're gonna fight it they're gonna
fight and Chavez Ravine at Dodger
Stadium I'm in also I think like this
this establishes my theory in this movie
that Michael B Jordan's character Adonis
Creed who's gonna be the last person to
figure out that Jonathan Majors is
trying to get him like I think he's
going to be justifying the whole time
like you guys are he's not coming for me
we're family and like Felicia Rashad's
the character is going to have to be
like no he's taking advantage of you and
then finally his wife is gonna get
through because like I mean the first
couple trolleys may look like oh Donnie
doesn't want him to come back like he's
annoyed that his friend from the past
this time I think he's gonna be like no
guys he's fine he's totally fine and
then he's gonna do something to totally
betray him and yeah and like that was a
more stylized I think the the original
trailer we got for Creed 3 kind of
spelled out the plot and like we've got
a lot more detail this was kind of a
shorter more action-packed uh thing but
it looked dope I love the three columns
right and framing that obviously some uh
pretty
um graphic workout footage because
anytime you got two extremely ripped uh
lead actors they want to show off all
those muscles in your thighs you gotta
show it on screen
oh yeah no those are Natty bodies
you know what we're not throwing stones
here uh as people who watch a lot of
superhero movies I don't care how those
actors got to look that way you know
what I mean I don't I don't ask I don't
ask the sculptor how he makes the clay
look so beautiful all right all right
that's right we could just we just did
my sponsor Andrew
Thomas Bechtel uh d-ball uh no uh uh so
there's not a ton to say about Creed 3
uh we'll be excited for that when it
comes out uh not too far from now right
is that uh March 3rd baby March just a
couple weeks away from grade three oh my
God it literally is less than a month
away yeah we're gonna see it and we'll
probably end up doing the breakdown that
might be a real fun movie IMAX I bet
like those punches also that that
Dodgers Stadium sequence looks great but
uh again uh we're excited to watch that
not a ton to talk about in that trailer
so we're gonna move on to a second
trailer or a variation on the trailer
release earlier this week for fast 10
fast x
Dominic
Toretto how do you choose the ones you
save Let's Race
he's coming for you with everything
you're about to learn all about fear
s
[Music]
what's the plan dog I'm not sure anymore
I never accept death when suffering is
old
you made one mistake you never took my
car
see you soon Dom
yourself and Whitney van laningham Yeah
I broke down that the full trailer we
got earlier this week yes that video is
already live on the channel go check
that out but you had mentioned there was
some new stuff yes we did not have Dom
going down the dam there's also some new
dialogue and also one of the main
mysteries of that first trailer is who's
I mean we know Brie Larson is supposedly
working for uh the Helen Mirren uh uh or
no Mr Nobody yeah Mr Nobody okay but it
definitely seems like Dom is carrying
her like passed out body at some point
so we think she may be doing some
flip-flopping in this because they also
has been heavily implied that she's a
member like she's related to someone in
the fast family we were thinking
possibly uh that she's Brian O'Connor's
sister perhaps you know maybe that's
there's another O'Connor in there uh go
back to our breakdown we speculate on
that a little bit I'm sure everybody and
I'll have more to send this new one but
yeah there was some there was new
dialogue Cena got some new lines in it
uh Mamoa got to add on to his lines uh
did uh I can't remember if you guys went
into this your video what kind of uh
head jewelry is Momoa I don't we didn't
do it because I it was yeah I'm always
worried that I'm gonna be like he's
wearing a funky headscarf and someone's
gonna be like That's a classic uh
whatever
um yeah well I'm not saying it in a mean
way there appeared to be there was some
chain element maybe some connected to an
earrings I think it's heavily implying
that he is Aquaman
well that's what they do these movies
have great bug parties no no franchise
other than butt party one through five
well it's so has better butts Furious
excuse me butt party one through five
yeah is that on thrust TV
my favorite by the way fast is gonna air
the Super Bowl next year no it's not
yeah oh yeah we got the rights to the
Super Bowl okay lies so my favorite part
about the fast X trailer is how 2003 it
feels how it still feels like it's like
a movie from the early 2000s it it gives
me the same
um uh the the lore uh oh my gosh what is
it Will Smith and yeah
and I'm like this is so fun this is so
fun it's chaotic I'll show it again you
guys talked about this in your previous
video but like
I don't even think they got the full
cast into that trailer there's so many
people in this movie I mean at one point
they show uh they show they show uh
Tyrese's character and he's literally
just like looking and then it cuts away
from me Statham's got two seconds yes
he's got a longer part in the Kevin Hart
uh commercial during the Super Bowl well
maybe that was the that might have been
the trade-off
uh justice for Han though Hans pretty
prominently featured in the longer
trailer he's Tokyo drifts so yes you
know what never tell her uh John Cena a
well represented in the video I used to
do the AAA through three floors of a
building oh yeah we had an adjustment
through the floor I wonder this is where
like MythBusters we need to do like a
MythBusters on this channel of like how
badly injured would you be even with a
compromised termite ridden floor also if
you attitude adjusted someone through it
both of you would be I mean would that
building better not be on the West Coast
or any place that gets earthquakes if
your floors can be so easily penetrated
there's no way that's earthquakes but
this is like my other thing is like the
debris like you get cut along your way
down of jagged wood and like you'd have
all these puncture wounds in your like
mid section you should do a break room
MythBusters and then you can do it to
Zach and then I will measure the
distance first of all Zach and I would
never turn on each other okay you would
only do moves to other people so you
better watch your back oh you're gonna
have your attitude adjustment I'm gonna
throw you through the wall that's what
Tommy thinks oh no oh my God oh my God
not the face
um uh yeah but again like that's gonna
be such a romp do we have a run time for
fast x yet I hope it's 45 hours
haven't the last few of the franchise of
creeped up to the two and a half three
hours we have no business one hour and
40 minutes but uh very excited for fast
x uh we're gonna get to the dial of
Destiny trailer obviously the Flasher
that we have so much to talk about there
but real quick
um you know I personally have always
been a little wary of using a VPN okay
because I'm like ah it's gonna slow
things down I know it's good for like
online protection and like accessing
content in different countries but it's
gonna slow everything down but then much
like Barry Allen realizing he's the
fastest person in the world I tried out
nordvpn guys and it's fast okay it's a
real fast the fastest way could I ever
have a VPN yes Tommy of course wow
great in fact you should grab yourself
some more VPN uh nor VPN is sponsoring
the break room this week as I have in
the past uh we're really happy with them
uh again they are uh the fastest VPN
um they don't drag down your internet
bandwidth or anything like that there's
no throttling you know be watching your
streaming video uh playing games
whatever you like
um we are actually going to use another
great use of vpns right is they can mask
your your country uh for accessing
things like Netflix and other streaming
services so you can access the libraries
in other countries so actually we have
to pick a movie yet we haven't picked
one but on Friday we're going to do a
nordvpn movie club where we watch a
movie that's on Netflix in another
country but not in the us and we're
going to talk about it and have fun with
it so hopefully if you're using nordvpn
out there you could watch the same movie
and join us let's go to Scandinavia
something with Angela Landsberg hell yes
I love all these ideas
so tune in on Tuesday when we picked the
the nordvpn uh movie
um it's easy to use nordvpn is you can
connect with one click or enable auto
connect for zero click protection that's
less than one click they have over 5000
servers and six 60 countries uh find a
server near you for better speed or
connect to a far away location to freely
explore the internet uh it's confirmed
by the speed test or vpn's the fastest
VPN out there no it can't reverse time
but everything else that you needed to
do it's very fast you can use up to six
devices and it's on every major platform
Windows Android iOS Mac OS Linux all of
those
um grab your exclusive nordvpn deal by
going to nordvpn.com breakroom the URLs
on screen right now and it's in this
video's description to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus GIF hey yo completely risk-free
with nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
again that's nordvpn.com break room we
thank them for sponsoring the show
helping us bring it to you and hey use
our URL it makes us look great yeah okay
also we want to shout out
we've got we've got some silly mugs here
on the desk if you're a fan of new
rockstars you might recognize that some
of these have become memes these are
former thumbnails on the channel uh
Tommy's uh in particular has really
memed up the internet and we're now
selling these because you know what you
can't get paid off a meme unless you put
it on a mug that's right we're mean
Muggin that's right hell yeah so so if
you want to sell a thumbnail I mean mug
nerd Riot dot shop yeah uh we've got
these there and cool quantumania
inspired merch uh like this cool uh rain
Eternal king shirt I love that shirt
people I get a lot of compliments on
that shirt if you're a member of the
Kang gang head over to nerd riot.shop
grab yourself this shirt other cool new
rock stars and Quantum media Inspire
merch we've got a great Last of Us
inspired shirt that's over there right
now for a limited time uh okay we need
to get back to some two some trailers
yes uh Jessica's pointing out the
preponderance of um slowed down hip-hop
and all these dreams at the end of every
movie it might put some respect on
12. I'm gonna miss everybody no respect
okay I think crazy bones Wishbone flesh
and Bone the whole game I think our next
one is is
Flash freaking cute Transformers rise of
the Beast okay
okay we cannot we can't watch the
trailer not Evan
oh it has been I'll explain it okay yeah
you can't we can't play the Transformers
trailer exhausted so this is perfect
because there has been a copyright
strike uh YouTube will get very angry if
we play the trailer but but Jessica it
is Mirage and we're getting Mirage
talking that is Pete Davidson in a very
cool tone a very different tone than we
hear Pete Davidson would you agree I
agree how how big do you think uh
mirage's serpentine belt is he's got a
big Serpentine Belt Energy but um it's a
lot it's a lot that we've seen from the
other Transformers rise of the Beast
trailer it's just a lot more of Mirage
actually talking to Anthony Ramos
Romanos Ramos character uh Noah and it's
so nice to hear Mirage and at the end
instead of getting the Transformers logo
we get a Porsche one so it's probably
like you said Zach co-branded right yeah
jumping out of a bumblebee jumping out
of a plane this is transformers all over
again was that the car I I
um
I uh I gotta say I did hear that Mirage
is dating Emily right Justin no get out
of here I did that she was with Haley
Haley's done I didn't see in the in the
previous year we didn't get to see like
the Mirage power kind of of the
duplicate yeah yeah it's very cool
oh was it okay yeah sorry it was uh
I blocked out the things that we saw in
the first didn't talk in the first year
no he did okay I'm I can't we can go to
the the next trailer right now but I
still genuinely my takeaway I can't get
over Pete Davidson's voice I forgot it
was Pete Davidson was casted as it and
then when you heard him I was like this
is now I understand I want to date him
oh it worked okay it worked hey you got
her one to date a car
um uh oh let's Okay so we we couldn't
play that trailer for copyright reasons
uh maybe we'll get to talk about it
later in the week but let's roll into
dial of Destiny Indiana Jones the dawn
of Destiny we can play that trailer yeah
they don't care you
movement my memory is a little fuzzy
are you still a Nazi
give him hell Indiana Jones
[Music]
sorry Jessica I'm trying I click it once
and then I'm like I did it
um we hadn't seen any of in fact was
that the first battle of Destiny trailer
we've gotten no no there has been it was
an earlier which we had the yeah and we
saw the preview at d23 and then they
released that this was I think a little
shorter of a trailer but way more Indie
heavy which I liked a lot of India this
was an indie movie we didn't see him
um did he say the Nazi part in the first
one I don't think so and then we didn't
see him traveling near that bridge in
the grassy knoll wait maybe he says I
hate Nazis yes he says this one he said
are you still a Nazi also
learning to not ruin that hat he punches
him through the hat and I think in the
movie The Original Trilogy he punches
through the Hat breaks the Hat
I need this hat I gotta I got a a gray
head I need to cover up uh and I mean
now do you think Harrison Ford you think
it triggers him a little bit when he
needs to be in scenes with crashing
planes oh maybe maybe I think it turns
him anytime has to be very good if it's
near a golf course for sure yeah yeah
um he's like cargo plane stick these are
fighting these crash all the time
Santa Monica public golf course that
last uh shot where they're jumping out
of the plane that's with Phoebe Waller
Bridge
tattoo you've shown it before but show
it again please there it is Boom
uh yeah it's your full body yeah body
Bridge we're very excuse me we're very
excited for that film uh man was that
was he saying are you still Nazi two
meds Mickelson's character we think I
think you want to be right I mean who's
the guy that plays uh the Nazi and our
movies in Marvel with the uh well he
becomes a robot oh Toby Jones yes he was
in the background oh okay that's why
he's like oh he's playing Nancy again
yeah or you know
yeah yeah poor meds Mickelson who's
Danish I believe but you know what if
you're anywhere in Europe that's not uh
the UK you get characters when you can
smile and still make people
uncomfortable if you smile it's like
it's perfect all-time great bad guy face
yeah oh yeah he's typecasted to play a
village playing Nazis as long as you
portray them bad and you make them sure
that they're evil yeah there's a lot of
great actors have played Nazis that's
right
um especially Tommy Tommy hey Catch
season two of hunters on Amazon right
now uh our own
hey okay I showed everybody your part
and they're so ecstatic free Wired
Magazine said oh God
again
um hey real quick uh we got a couple
other things we want to talk about this
week
our second channel is launching new
Rockstar's deep dive uh what was uh you
know we're branching out like timelines
we must Branch our baby boy Eric Voss is
launching under the new rockstars
umbrella Deep dive we are so excited for
this he's got a couple killer videos
they're gonna be live on launch day
which is this Thursday the 15th I think
nope it's Friday the 17th my man thank
you yeah um and he's going to be doing a
live
breakdown of Ant-Man and the WASP
Quantum Mania I saw him do it kind of a
tech rehearsal of this this is going to
be nuts you're going to want to watch
this uh you get a little sneak peek into
like what happens behind the scenes in
new rock stars but in the in front of
the scenes kind of way uh we're really
excited for that you can subscribe to
new Rockstar's Deep dive right now so
you'll get notifications when those
videos go live and you know what this
means what new rock stars need a channel
anymore
I was giving practical information
Jessica had to make a joke some people
are always going to go for the easy bit
I'm always going to give you remember
someone some would argue we've always
been a family but now it's a it's a
family of this family is in big trouble
uh and I and I did have to divest all my
shares of thrust uh as we are network
now I'm not allowed to be the Principal
uh for us okay now another thing that we
cannot play because apparently we're
getting some copyright issues with it is
the Mario commercial yeah again it is so
sorry you I want you to talk about Mario
I'm just saying Paramount does this a
lot no shame to Paramount but sometimes
with copyright stuff it's really hard to
replay their stuff so the Mario being
one and then I didn't realize Mario was
a Paramount oh no it's Universal I
thought it was Universal Universal does
it too uh Paramount Universal so that's
why
um Transformers in this aren't allowing
us to play it well you know what they're
lost guys because we were gonna go off
but let me just tell you about this
trailer because a lot of stuff that's
right in my wheelhouse one it's using
the original Mario Brothers rap from the
TV show starring Captain Lou Albano the
late great professional wrestler and if
you've never seen the clip look up Super
Mario Brothers hip hop dancing because
Captain Lou Albano has the body that I
have and the guy who plays Luigi has the
body that Zach has and the dancers in
the video clearly have different bodies
and they keep cutting to the below the
waist doing funky feet moves and then
they cut back up and Captain Lou
Albano's like
he's doing like the arms crossed hip hop
dude at the end of this week we won't
yes yes we will do that maybe we will
what if we kissed uh no but what I love
about this is this is a fake trailer the
woman in the trailer is voiced by Cyndi
Lauper who was dear dear friends with
Captain Lou Albano yes and he was in a
lot of her music videos and she actually
I believe walked him out at a major
wrestling table you know that it was
WrestleMania but she was his valet yeah
on TV yeah when she was a mega pop star
she was like she loves wrestling Girls
Just Want to Have Fun and all of that so
it's like it's fun to bring that full
circle uh yeah and it's a fun so it's a
fake commercial for I think an
in-universe plumbing company uh the
phone number that you can call that I
was gonna call before this and I forgot
so someone else maybe yeah maybe we'll
call live on the air uh tomorrow maybe
or Tuesday uh but yeah it's it's I think
programming wise we have shows Monday
Tuesday not Wednesday this week thank
you Tommy thank you uh so maybe tomorrow
um but yeah there's no new footage
necessarily from the movie I guess
presumably this whole that commercial
might be in the movie yeah I'm wondering
that because it doesn't seem yeah it's
kind of expensive I mean the
Ghostbusters movies they show a
Ghostbusters okay they got some Korean
animators working overtime that's what
they did in Megan so it can start with a
commercial that is for uh oh it's smart
yeah before they get sucked into the
Mushroom Kingdom kind of stuff uh but
it's fine
before we get we're gonna we're gonna
get to this awesome uh Flash trailer we
want to shout out a couple super chats
uh a couple of the super chats are
referencing The Flash trailer so we'll
come back to you
um uh
Marvel nerd 92. hey guys I watch you
every day what about the depressing
episode five of Last of Us well it was
sad depressing uh you know moving is is
how I would phrase it or you know
emotional um I thought it was hilarious
Tommy's broken inside uh Jessica Brandon
and never mind I've recently been given
some information on an episode I didn't
watch okay oh you're you're gonna says
fine
Jessica stop Jessica Brandon
so I'm so sorry
yeah yeah yeah
no Tommy uh Jessica Brandon and Anna uh
did an after show for that episode that
is live on our Channel now it came out
Friday night when the episode dropped
because of course they had to move it
out of the way for the Super Bowl and
Eric voss's breakdown of that episode's
already up where you found a lot of uh
fun details and thematic stuff and it
was it was uh it was a good a gut punch
of an episode I think no more people
will die but I'm probably right okay
well yeah they don't got that many more
gas
um well-rounded Mom saying I was so
hoping for Logan's Loki season two picks
yes well-rounded mom we got that's such
a good name we got no uh Disney plus
stuff at all okay mandalorians starting
in a couple weeks maybe that's
understandable they don't need to show a
commercial for that but secret Invasion
when are we getting this show you know
what we did get the Disney 100 we did
guys which doesn't count which hey that
is a celebration I don't know why
they're still promoting Mary Poppins and
Frozen uh those things came out a long
time ago but Frozen you know what you
know what that commercial was for that
commercial was for the kids ages three
through eight they were watching the
Super Bowl with their parents it came on
very early in the Super Bowl to get them
to go I need to go to Disneyland I need
to go to Disney World that was not about
upcoming media projects that was about
selling ticks to the parks selling hotel
rooms selling drugs has Eric uh it's
been mentioned before so I'm not playing
anything but Eric is about or is
planning on doing like a deep dive video
about trailers yes and how they affect
us yes and tell me how I watched every
trailer during the Super Bowl and only
that one almost got me to tear up and
that's where it was I think it was the
music because I was like in my head
immediately when I got to inside out
part I was like if there was no music in
this I wouldn't be affected what was
that what music were they playing Never
Gonna lift you up Never Gonna Let You
Down how many cookies
well and they were like there was some
like Make-a-Wish type shots in there
that was definitely meant to like kind
of pull out the heartstrings uh real
quick nerd Mafia again also refuting
Tommy's uh catering more fake news
um saying he doesn't think that quill is
dead he said uh caterpillars don't turn
into goo
um what do you get well prove it when
they're in their poopa stage uh uh but
he's in Quill's probably not dead when
he's being carried like a uh like a sack
of potatoes by Gamora in that shot
because rocket is sipping a soda like no
big deal it looks like Mafia is a bit of
a know-it-all
uh thank you to everybody in the chat
we're gonna answer all the uh or try to
get to the uh flash related ones after
we watch this pretty dope Flash trailer
should we roll footage
foreign
what's happening
you've changed the future
and you changed the path
what did you do
want some help you're you are you're
yeah
I'm Batman
[Music]
oh watch the full trailer online now
the flash only beaters June 16.
so that is not the three minute totally
extended version you can watch online
again copyright reasons we can only play
the that's the version that played in
the Super Bowl the shorter thing we're
gonna try to talk about the stuff that
was not in that that we found really
interesting obviously a lot more Cara
Supergirl in the longer extended trailer
that was kind of one of the big
takeaways for me I'm like oh this is a
new character right yeah I mean you know
based on what they're saying you know
one of the flashes gets rid of it
creates a world with no metahumans and
that makes us vulnerable to Invasion
from Aliens which is I think you know
where we get Zod so Who's Gonna Save Us
it's gonna have to be other aliens right
it's gonna have to be other kryptonians
possibly lanterns someone from the
lantern who are possibly a Martian
Manhunter you know like those that to me
are the things that we haven't seen yet
that makes the most sense uh based on
that trailer but there are some
Mysteries right like who's the old man
with long hair yeah
back to your first part because the
director did an interview where he did
say that it was going to be a movie with
a retired Batman an alien girl and two
idiots so I think those that's the team
that's going to actually be fighting uh
Michael Shannon the two idiots the two
berries the alien being uh
Supergirl and then Michael Keaton's
Batman yeah so I don't know if we'll see
I would love to see the Green Lantern
but I think the movie is circled around
those I don't think it'll be Green
Lantern our Green Lantern is Hal Jordan
or Jon Stewart or
Scott I think it'll be someone from the
Green Lantern Corps you know one of the
aliens well and and and so like we we
see in the trailer two Batmans we get
Ben Affleck and Michael Keaton right
like we think that that's probably that
Flack on the the motorcycle it's not
quite the um the Christian Bale
motorcycle had one wheel this is a
two-wheel version so that's him there's
some other shots where it's like you
can't exactly tell which Batman it is I
think Eric Boss is doing a full
breakdown he'll be microscopically
examining each of those Batman but um
yeah so one of the shots we just noticed
and we're kind of speculating on there's
that shot of somebody with long gray
hair shirtless from from the back with
like doors kind of opening into like a
gray space yeah I was guessing is that
Michael is this old Michael Keaton and
they've given him an old old gray wig
and that's kind of like because it it
has like a Wayne Manor kind of Batcave
look to it but I don't know that they
would give him long hair I think it's uh
I want it to be negative a negative
flash reverse flash yeah I want to be
villainous what if it was uh old Aquaman
and he's just atrophy get out of here
but you had said you said it could be
Old Flag could be old flash now I I
would put you guys on the spot
we saw with Spider-Man no way home
Redemption for Andrew Garfield
Spider-Man yes
can you say with the absolute certainty
George Clooney is not going to be in
this movie no I cannot I don't think we
can well and I would love that
glamoring and have defended that Batman
as much it's it's a little bit more
complicated but I think top gun Maverick
showed us I mean you put him in the
right circumstances Val Kilmer yeah
could be out there this is sad it's
tough everyone this that was my favorite
Batman was Val Kilmer and I remember
everyone making fun of me my entire life
as people know when uh our friend of the
show hot Mike was on he's reanimated
Burl Ives is that westnet
I don't like the bones the Bones have
been returned and we know Christian Bale
alive and well in good shape uh not
against doing superhero movies
um maybe but maybe that's bad Overkill
this is still a Flash movie afterwards
that's too much
um but yeah a lot of a lot of good
Keaton in this trailer and again not the
version we just played but in that full
version a lot of who we think is
Supergirl right like the costume at the
end when she's flying next to uh the jet
uh also I think Jessica you pointed out
the first time we see her in kind of the
potato sack looking thing looks like a
prison outfit it's like a prison outfit
and normally I remember
um especially an Injustice the game she
looks it looks like the same Garb but
it's like no you see there's buckles on
the back so she was imprisoned oh in a
straight jacket oh yeah which no
wouldn't actually container she was
playing ball absolutely not yeah who
knows I mean maybe their their buckles
are made of kryptonite or something like
that well again like the the line I
created a world with no meta-humans yes
now you know flash very powerful
character we know he's going to do some
time traveling type of stuff he doesn't
have the ability to create worlds he's
not like at a a Nexus being kind of
equivalent so like what does that mean
did he go back in time and kind of like
we assume he kind of adjusted events
Butterfly Effect style it must be right
I think it's just that that power no one
I don't well that we've seen in the DCU
has that power and ability to run so
fast that they alter time so I think
that's just what we're going to be
blowing out in this world is the fact
that he's I think I said this that he's
our doctor strange except for he's just
a little dumb boy but he's so fast that
he's altering time and space and I think
you know the not that they're going to
follow the CW shows certainly but you
know the the the creation of metahumans
a majority of the many humans was the
Star Labs explosion that creates Barry
Allen's ability to run fast so he can't
stop that because then he's not the
flash anymore good point did you watch
all of the Flash on CW you know you know
a lot about first four seasons Five
Seasons because you you know so much
about Arrow too I'm always I watched a
lot of air I loved it I love it uh a
couple just on this topic of the the
long gray-haired character well-rounded
mom coming back in the Super Chat thank
you old Alfred
speculating Andy Circus could be
anything now Andy sergas is the Alfred
in battenson oh right World Jeremy Irons
it could be that Flex Alfred yeah and of
course Michael Keaton the actor who
played Michael Keaton's Alfred has
passed away but he also played Val
Kilmer and George Clooney yes he was the
one yes through line an [__] but and
in the trailer we see like all I know
the bats come out the cave I get it but
it's like this is a retired Batman uh no
one has seen him Barry was very excited
to be like this is Batman he doesn't
come out
um do we think Alfred is alive also
would Alfred be walking around shirtless
that's a bold move by the butler you
know what I mean
I think it's very I think the the the
most logical thing is that is an aged
Barry Allen who has gone so far maybe he
lives in Bruce Wayne's maybe lives in
Wayne Manor now like he's like you know
he knows where he is he knows he's got
cool gear he's got fun computers cool
cars absolutely T-Rex uh bads in a super
Chad saying I didn't see anyone mention
the shoulder pads on Keaton Batman like
Flashpoint animated movie I didn't even
catch that that's cool uh the six-inch
Galaxy saying uh flash looks amazing has
a ton of potential show you better
believe it according to James Gunn and
and there's another James Gunn thing I
want to talk about here in a second
according to James Gunn this is the best
superhero movie he's ever seen and
there's a quick reminder to all the fire
fans that watch if anyone ever
approaches you and offers you a trip to
the six-inch Galaxy you tell them no
not going you don't you don't oh is that
I'm curious that was that person's
username I don't know what it means
here's the six inch gallon I'm just
saying if anyone offers you a trip to
the six inch Galaxy you tell them you're
not interested I think what also won us
over with that trailer and I didn't I
honestly wouldn't have known it worked
was the echo effect of like clearly this
is time and there's two berries and
that's why everything like everything
that was said was said again also if
you're like me and you need subtitles on
you didn't hear it you can catch it
again in another second yeah good point
good point
um uh yeah the the James Gunn of it all
so we know James Gunn has announced for
the dceu plan going forward he is
working they are working on a Supergirl
movie right a very specific Supergirl
story this movie appears be introducing
a Supergirl no not the same thing we
think this actress is not going to be or
I don't know I think I think it is I
think this is the first because we don't
know anyone from the DCU slave right no
one's been casted this is the first
reveal would be Supergirl I think it is
I wanted to be I think she would be a
good super girl look how strong she is
look how strong our girl is so she's
almost like 27 it works yeah by the way
people on board with the third Batman 71
oh ah he's winning well of course if
somebody offers you more Batman's or
less Batmans you will always take more
Batman
um uh free girl with a in the chat
saying well we see an end credit scene
with a Booster Gold I will say no
because I think the Booster Gold project
is too new but a Blue Beetle maybe that
would make a little bit more sense for
getting a Blue Beetle movie this year
blue beetles in Philly or New York oh
that's a great question it's something
East Coast okay I'll tell you that
um yes uh but um uh Sandman 65 a chance
of a bail Batman yeah yeah we're
speculating I mean that could be right
what were the villains that we didn't
get in any of the trailers for no way
home they kind of gave us most of the
big ones right but they I don't know
they held out on a on a lizard maybe or
I think we saw the lizard yeah briefly
like a lizard towel the secret from no
way home was obviously the two
Spider-Man right like yes they held
those out to the very end yeah so maybe
hopefully there there are some things
they're not revealing in the flash yet
uh uh will every uh King Lee Clark
saying will everyone die in The Flash
everyone I don't know so much as maybe
not die so much as like be removed from
a timeline might not not have ever
existed I think yeah I think the
ending's gonna have to be calculated for
James Gunn to successfully
or or just set like it'll set like
how do I I want to say this so it's I'm
confusing myself thinking about it it'll
set people back in their timelines and
the Flash we end up with in the movie
will be the flash in the DC well he
could yeah and our that flash could set
up time where he's with his mom again
right and all these other things so
maybe that's just how famously in the
flash if he tries to if his mom comes
back to life nothing good can come up
that's true that's like the one it's
like the left it's like any movie that
was all this time the monkey's pie yeah
yeah you you try to you mess with things
unpunished yes
oh no dude you're witch no good mom goes
unpunished premieres on thrust
ERS uh starring Kirk Cameron Candace
Cameron his husband and wife I love that
wrong uh that's so wrong uh thank you uh
I think you know we have a lot to talk
about all right we've got a full body
yeah we we've got we're gonna have to go
back through all these trailers here at
new rock stars both on the break room
this show which is going live every uh
weekday 3 P.M uh Pacific uh but also
we'll have reactions trailer breakdowns
a lot of really fun content about all
these great trailers and time of
speculating at the beginning of this
episode Disney's Disney's holding back I
think they've got they got bombs to drop
and they're loaded and they're ready to
release them also if they play these
trailers also before quantumania yeah
because we're not seeing trailers at our
private screenings it just goes straight
into the movie oh uh my friend is
showing me uh the six inch galaxies
I'm not gonna watch that with you he's
no friend of yours
but and speaking of which what a huge
week this is forget all these trailers
and me otherwise Quantum Mania comes out
this week the Deep dive comes out this
week the Deep dive comes out this week
we're getting another Last of Us on
Sunday it's a it's a great week for
content on the channel our VPN is
hooking up the movie club that's right
uh maybe we'll get a little uh bed knobs
and Broomsticks
it's not that good I haven't seen it
since I was one kid uh but thank you all
come back uh party with us the rest of
this week uh we've got a lot of really
fun content coming on the channel we
appreciate you for staying up late here
with us on the Super Bowl Sunday or or
whenever you're watching this video uh
like And subscribe no I'm so sorry I
didn't mean to react like that I just
thought I haven't seen the page master
and I don't know where to find it maybe
we should watch that on board it doesn't
exist anyway I cannot find it anywhere
oh I bet you there's some little country
where the net like uh algorithm that has
the page match the page
is one of the best macaulays um so uh
thank you all so much uh for watching uh
this show again Watch Tommy and
Whitney's first 10 trailer breakdown
keep an eye out Jessica has some really
fun videos coming out on the channel
this week
yes a big a big quantumania video coming
out in a few days I'm doing a review
also a non-spoiler review
my mom who's up almost to midnight on
the East Coast for watching thanks mags
and thank you to all thank you to
well-rounded mom and all moms out there
huh how about that uh I love my Mom see
you guys soon uh have a great uh rest of
your day or evening and keep it Gucci to
moochie
foreign
[Music]